welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon hosted the Benjamin
Dixon show filling in for David for the
rest of the week let's get right to it
young progressives are winning we're
seeing a trend around the country where
a new generation of leaders are emerging
to take the the helm of the Democratic
Party to be the face of a new generation
of leaders that are quite frankly to the
moat for the most part more progressive
than what we've seen in at least in my
lifetime
last night a Jana Presley who's a Boston
City Council member I'll stood sitting
the ten term ten term representative
from the seventh District in
Massachusetts Michael Capuano and to be
sure Capuano has a a record of being
true extremely progressive so the win
last night wasn't a referendum like
we've seen across the country of
centrist Democrats being ousted those
Democrats who go to the Third Way and
triangulate last night was more about a
generational shift and a changing of the
guard in fact many one report from last
night said that they didn't have
anything against the incumbent they
actually like the incumbent but they
felt that it was time for new faces and
new blood to go to Washington DC and
this is interesting because one of the
things I discussed about two years ago
right after the election was that the
Democratic Party did not have a bench
the Democratic Party did not have a deep
enough bench where we could look and see
like here are the competitors to lead
the Democratic Party into the future all
we had were a lot of aging old men quite
frankly and now we're seeing a very
diverse group of people with
qualifications who are progressive who
are running on Medicare for all some are
running on abolishing ice some are more
further to the left than others but
we're seeing a new wave of progressive
leadership going into going to Congress
and it's a very important shift that's
happening right now I want to pull up a
picture of a Jana Presley and and you
can see in the picture that she has this
photo with another leader another leader
of the Democratic
young leader of the Democratic Party who
hasn't even taken office yet Alexandria
Acacio Cortez who herself al stood a 10
term representative in New York Joe
Crowley and so you know it's a very
interesting time to see a new wave of
leadership taking over the Democratic
Party because that's what was necessary
to begin with it has to be bold in brash
leadership that's willing to fight
another example of a new leader in the
Democratic Party Stacey Abrams she
bested the Democratic establishment here
in Georgia she could pull the photo up
on the screen she is going to she's
running as a Democratic nominee to
become the first african-american
governor and quite frankly one of the
first Democratic governors in Georgia in
a long time right Georgia has been
controlled by Republicans and in time in
memorium I can't even remember the last
time a Democrat was in power same thing
in the state of Florida Andrew Gilliam
he definitely upset the Democratic
establishment the daughter of one a
former governor I believe it's Graham if
my memory serves me correctly he beat
her in the primaries and now he's
running against one of Donald Trump's
clones to become the first
african-american governor of Florida as
well as the first Democratic governor in
the last twenty years there hasn't been
a Democratic governor in the state of
Florida in 20 years so when you add this
together and actually before I go any
further I want to mention a local race
in st. Louis where you had the young guy
Wesley Bell who put out Bob McCulloch
from the st. Louis County Prosecuting
Attorney position he beat him right and
so they're there examples of this all
across the country were young idealistic
energetic qualified and ready to fight
progressives are winning so this is
encouraging and and in a way I mean to
almost be cliche I think this should be
encouragement for anyone who believes
that the system needs to change to run
because we're seeing a shifting of the
old vanguard the old guard there they're
there they're being voted out and in
some cases it's nothing against their
politics and like in Massachusetts is
really nothing against kapwa knows
politics I mean he was a progressive guy
but it's also something you've been
there ten ten terms twenty years right
it's time for new faces to get in there
who are just as progressive and who are
ready to fight this new there's a new
battle front that this is not the same
politics of the 90s what's going on
today is not the same thing that we saw
in the 90s there is no opportunity for
bipartisanship well and anyone and let
me qualify that because people may be
offended by that sentence we're dealing
with a very rabid strain of conservatism
that has been playing hardball politics
with the Democrats since the 90s but
Democrats aren't didn't get the message
until I don't know if they've gotten the
message yet you know because you still
have people trying to be reasonable with
these Republicans when Republicans have
made it clear that they are playing a
zero-sum winner-takes-all
battle of attrition type of politics
where they are not going to move an inch
where they will break every rule they
will break every norm they will ignore
every reality they would deny the truth
they will rewrite history and they will
come they will betray their own belief
system their own ideology simply to win
and if your mindset is stuck in the time
when you first came to Congress back in
the 90s and you have this nostalgia for
a better time of politics a better
period of politics that you experienced
when you first came in the 90s you are
decidedly not equipped to fight the
style of conservatism that has been
there since the 90s but you just didn't
realize it until 20 years later so this
is not a knock at their individual
politics in what they believe
ideologically it is to say that we need
a new generation of leaders who
understand the lay of the land they
understand the game that Republicans are
playing and
they are going to play hardball against
them today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book of BS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on bling cos
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k mas